wenn es draußen war es vom schnee ist
liegt der duft in der luft der jedem
wohl bekannteste
die weihnachtsfeierlichkeiten sally
bakterien backt verpackt in der
weihnachtszeit sagt sally band wird
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sli fällt
heute gibt's ganz klassische plätzchen
wir machen nämlich linser plätzchen oder
auch wie bei uns genannter brötchen
catcher den austrag hinter brötchen also
hilda wollten wir nicht aber für mich
sind es ausgeliehen so plätzchen also
hin zu rock das was gesagt ist gesagt
linse plätzchen genau und werde hilda
häuschen das ist ein ganz normaler
mürbeteig wirklich sehr möge es ist kein
ei enthalten sondern wirklich nur butter
butter zucker und mehl sind nur die
standard zutaten und aus dem gleichen
tag dürfte sanierer damit ihrer
freundinnen gemeinsam noch ausstechen
machen und die sind wirklich super
schnell ist vorbereitet und gehören für
mich einfach immer mit dazu ich singe
auch weil diese auch liebsten sind
liebsten meines tages plötzlich mit
marmelade auf jeden fall
ich habe hier nach himbeermarmelade mit
drin und ich zeige euch jetzt mal ganz
schnell die zutaten für den mürbeteig da
ist nämlich super rush vorbereitet
[Musik]
natürlich steckt sind wenn ja gerade
dass sie gerade in der schule ist gehört
zum nächsten geschickt wo sie ist genau
aber jetzt einmal die zutaten habe ich
von dir probieren
mit den magic brauche ich 100 gramm
puderzucker 200 gramm kalte butter 300
gramm mehl etwas von den extrakt eine
prise salz und wer möchte fügt noch ein
bisschen tonkabohne dazu ist ein ganz
besonderes gewürz das riecht für mich
leicht nach vanille aber ein bisschen
auch nach waldmeister also ganz ganz
toll und man darf aber davon nur ganz
wenig nehmen
wie willst du erst einmal den
puderzucker den gebe ich es in der
küchenmaschine ihr könnt den teig aber
auch ganz gut mit der hand verkneten
ihr dürft ihr nur nicht so lange kneten
damit er eben schon kalt bleibt da kommt
jetzt die butter mit rein und jetzt
vermisse ich erstmal zwei zutaten
jetzt könnt ihr auch das salz und weil
ein extrakt zufügen
und wenn sich die zutaten land verbunden
haben kommt jetzt nur noch das mädel und
ein bisschen von der tonkabohne dazu und
dann verkehrt sich die zutaten nur noch
solange wir sind schöner geschmeidiger
teig entsteht die tonkabohne hatte ich
einen wahnsinnig intensives aroma also
ganz sparsam verwenden
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich den track heraus und
kann ihn einfach mit den händen zu einer
kugel formen
[Musik]
die kugel wird jetzt in eine schale
gelegt und dann kann ich sie ein
bisschen flach drücken und abdecken und
für etwa eine stunde im kühlschrank
ruhen lassen
auch danke herrschen einkommen gemalt
habe ich das zeigen die ein hund hatte
echt noch ja ich komme mal mit der teig
ist gut durch gekühlt ich habe ihn jetzt
auch gerade noch mal kurz durchgeknetet
so lässt es sich besser ausrollen ich
habe eine silikon unterlage und da
braucht man auch nur ganz ganz wenig
mehl damit datei gibt auch gleichmäßig
dick wird nämlich jetzt bei holzstäbe
die am 5 mm stärke und da gehört kann
ich das jetzt schon ausrollen und mit
diesem tag kann man auch richtig toller
ausgleich alle plätzchen machen
[Musik]
mit einer großen palette kann man die
teigplatten immer schön hoch nehmen ohne
dass das kaputtgeht wird nämlich einfach
verschiedene aussteller ich nehme die
herzchen und stern war das jetzt einfach
schön ausstechen und parallel dazu
natürlich immer ein pärchen mit einem
loch in der mitte damit da die marmelade
reinkommen kann
[Musik]
durch die plätzchen fertig ausgesprochen
eine portion teil habe ich noch für
samira vorbereitet die darf nämlich
gleich auch aus sicher plätzchen machen
die dann mit eigelb bestreichen und dann
noch ein bisschen zucker deckel drauf
streuen
die kommen jetzt bei mir in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 190 grad ober
unterhitze für etwa sechs bis acht
minuten
sie sollten noch schön hell bleiben aber
der antrag so ein bisschen hellbraun
werden
und wichtig ist dass der teig ist nicht
so warm wird also beim kneten ausrollen
ansonsten stellte die so noch mal für
eine halbe stunde in den kühlschrank
damit sie beim backen ihre form nicht
verlieren
[Musik]
jetzt sind die plätzchen gebacken und
ich habe es ja auch komplett abkühlen
lassen und alle die jetzt noch haben
werden jetzt mit süßem schnee bestreut
das ist ein extra feiner puderzucker der
auf der oberfläche nicht schmilzt
jetzt könnt ihr die marmelade eurer wahl
nehmen ich habe jetzt hier hin wäre und
zwar ist die fein passiert und ohne
stückchen habe ich ein bisschen erwärmt
das ein bisschen flüssiger wird aber
auch nicht ganz flüssig ist jetzt nehme
ich hier gerade so ein unterteil
da kommt ein bisschen marmelade drauf
nicht so viel damit nicht ausläuft dann
ein bisschen verteilen
deckel drauf wir jetzt hier oben zu
wenig drin ist könnte auch hier oben
noch ein bisschen marmelade rhein geben
[Musik]
die kinder brötchen sind jetzt fertig
und die gefallen mir optisch schon mal
richtig gut
die auch du darfst es gerne frisch
probieren aber ich muss dazu sagen wenn
man sie ein pakt eine nacht in seine
dose als eine keksdose dann werden sie
eben richtig zeit also ich mag sie am
liebsten wenn es in der nacht stehen und
dann sind sie ganz fein ganzkörper nur
so sieht's aus richtig cool ich probiere
es jetzt ja und da kann man nichts
falsch
wobei doch man kann das falsch machen
viele machen so dass du nämlich beim tai
verwenden und dann ist es einfach nicht
ganz so möge und die sind dann irgendwie
viel zu hart und knusprig vor und so
werden sie eben richtig schön fein und
zart und es kommt eben daher dass wir
noch butter mit drin haben und kein ei
und das eben auch nur ganz kurz geknetet
wird aber schon immer aus abgebissen
wer die weihnachtslieder also lagern
würde ich dir jetzt in einer keksdose
einfach die erste schicht plätzchen rein
backpapier drüber und dann die zweite
und dritte schicht so bestätigt man eben
nichts und dann sind sie wirklich
mehrere wochen haltbar da die mama dir
noch mal aufgekocht werden kann ich
jetzt nur noch in form eines sportlers
machen falls ihr das rezept nachmachen
möchte schaut of selling ist lobte
vorbei da steht noch mal alles ganz
genau ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß
und nachmachen und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal bis dann tschüss macht's
gut und macht es um ihren kindern ganz
einfach wieder und männer und lasst eure
männer alleine macht dann darfst du
jetzt packen
nein das war nur ein spaß ich habe jetzt
nur vor der kamera gesagt okay lass die
männer ausgespielt
[Musik]